the way that I Define resilience is the
ability to accept understand process and
grow through emotional pain first of all
we have to accept and acknowledge it
next we have to release and process it
then we have to understand it inquire
what is my mind making this about learn
from it and then we can grow through it
and the final a is to act to act in line
with our values and our vision because
I've worked with so many Business
Leaders and and Visionaries and CEOs who
whenever something huge or detrimental
happens particularly to their business
or in their personal life they lose
sight of their vision and we all need
something to move towards and how we do
it is so crucial Royal Robin of this
pioneering rock climbing and he said
getting to the top is nothing the way
you do it is everything